if you read more into what he was
talking about in terms of not just BBS
but like the superhero genre Civil War
and you started those YouTube followers
reviewers what do you think's the
different infinity still yeah how he
really believes that it was my twin in
the his petition to get Fox to crossover
with the Marvel he's gonna be the new
Wolverine is you're gonna be oh but that
would be cool
the weekly mail gifts an update on we
come back here because permanent
segments of our channel all about Ocwen
so a couple weeks because I've been like
very vocal about my comeback for Mel
Gibbs yeah and a couple weeks ago I put
out a video like before the release of
blood father which I saw by the way I've
did video called white Mel Gibson
deserves to come back and now suddenly
it's been a few weeks since that video
some new things have happened and people
are raving about Mel Gibson's probably
finally gonna have this comeback this
year and I called it I said it was gonna
be this year because blood father and
the prophecy blood father showed that he
was gonna give a great performance and
then hacks are rich he's gonna show the
world he can still direct currently the
film has a 93% Rotten Tomatoes at the
Venice Film Festival a lot of people
reported that he got a 10-minute
standing ovations yeah after the film
was done Toby's this Mel Gibson comeback
isn't a serious thing I have ever talked
about and you're gonna make some weird
Spanish talking joke it's ten minutes
ten minutes especially Mel Gibson's new
movie got a 10 minute standing ovation
did you know that people really seem to
like Mel's counting on me to help him
get this come hey so I didn't release a
review of blood father I just didn't
make the time to do it yet but I guess
it give you a quick little review right
now the film itself I didn't think was
the greatest I mean I thought the film
was kind of uneven and choppy and I felt
a lot of moments go just played out but
the one thing that everyone universally
agrees on is Mel Gibson does a great job
without specifically his performance in
that movie is the main reason and one of
the few reasons I could come up with to
actually watch that specific though I'm
not just saying that cuz I love him I'm
saying that because it's true he is the
best thing in that film that's the thing
that's always really interesting to me
about Mel Gibson is every time I see him
on screen I am reminded that this guy
does have a magic well yeah he's doing a
performance like hey there's a lot of
stuff III still
kind of haven't fully made booth about
like who Mel Gibson is and like whether
or not I'd like to see him like in full
force but every time I see him on the
screen which is arguably the part that
matters most it's like even the
Expendables 3 like I don't really care
that much about the Expendables movies
and when he was on screen oh yeah most
of who I knew that when they watch
Expendables 3 don't like it but they
talk about this monologue that Mel
Gibson gives when these handcuffs yeah
and it's like every time I know Mel
Gibson's is something I can think to
myself like if I drop money to see that
you know I know at least that guy will
not have wasted you know yeah any any
effort and I really didn't care for
machete kills and it's jam-packed with
celebrity appearances yeah machete
killed yet the one thing I liked was
he's also still done some good films
Edge of Darkness is a little bit more
debatable in terms of whether or not you
think that's just a good film in general
he did the beaver which he did a really
good job and I thought that was a really
good film get the gringo I think is
amazing it's on Netflix if you haven't
seen get the gringo really should have
gone in a theater release I think it's a
fantastic film Mel Gibson does a
fantastic job in it too blood father is
a great job and I like how he's working
with
I think redesigning his image like I
think you look at the stepladders first
you do kind of a weird indie movie like
the beaver then you do a pretty good
version of what you used to do and then
you do a movie where you're the mostly
good thing about this yes and now we'll
we can and now you got to direct
something and now you can come back he's
smart with what he's doing because he
takes on these roles specifically when
he does like the leading dramatic roles
now when he does like a fun supporting
role in the film yeah but when he does
like a leading dramatic role he takes on
these roles that kind of similar
representations to his public personal
life image it he has you know because
especially in blood father his first
scene he's in an AAA meeting as
alcoholism struggles are a well-known
thing so to have that be a big part of
his character a guy who has alcoholism
struggles but put him in like kind of
this badass action role he's a smart
maneuver for him I think he's being very
uh what's the word strategic in what
he's doing specifically this year
because with hacksaw Rich coming out and
and the wonderful feedback it's getting
the concept of what he's doing with
hacksaw rigid but in terms of his
directing because he
brave hard Passion of the Christ and I
know he did Apocalypto but brave hunter
passion the Chrysler is two biggest
directorial efforts and those films a
lot of that is about love and heart and
hacksaw reg seems to have that too in
this world of violence it's a but love
is such an essential thing to making
this work yeah and the value of a
peaceful person and a person who wants
to help but doesn't want to fight like
you know like there's an interesting
idea working there that's not the same
idea that you get all the time and
especially coming from him with what we
know about him in our associations for
him to do a movie with a piece at the
core of it is a nice thing for you see
because Mel Gibson to me is a lot like
Tom Cruise in the sense that I when I'm
right here those names I'm like these
guys seem like they have really good
judgment and they put a lot into their
work really good judgment at least in
terms of movies and like Mel Gibson is
is the guy I struggle with probably the
most in terms of like separating the art
from the artist cuz if I'm just talking
about the movies man like he's a
terrific actor I think like every time I
watch him I'll give some performance
pretty much I'm like yeah I totally see
the magic dude's got chops and he's
proven he makes a good movie what's
funny is the thing is really like cuz
this there's two reports of him this
week the standing ovations at Venice
Film Festival and the fact you slam BVS
ha I don't want to criticize more BBS
it's just interesting to me that it's
like suddenly his opinion on it it like
matters again movies you then this is so
many people are talk not like Batman
Superman so many people are really
talking about it like every news site i
sees is mentioning that mel gibson
didn't like BBS see i can't tell if
that's if that's more on the virtue of
hey we're listening to mel more again or
if it's more on the virtue of like this
is how much we don't like this movie
it's like it's great too because mel
gibson's talking [ __ ] and it's the first
time in a long time where he's talked
[ __ ] and we're all going you know what
most of us agree with you don't oh no
and you can join this fight despite the
fact that right now he's in his just
come back period he's not in his highly
profile station right yeah it's like
he's at the party were like eight
keep it cool and you can hang out just
don't go too far yeah and so despite the
fact that that's only where is that
currently yeah I think it's still a big
deal because we all know his line of
work we know the you know lineage of his
directing of his directing efforts and
his and his acting roles to go for
enough for him to give a critical
opinion on a film for us to be to like
hear about you know yeah I was not
talking about like something in life but
he's talking about a movie like I said
it's that art from the artist thing when
he makes the movie like you can still
make a good movie I think you could be
great in a superhero s film III don't
think it necessarily a DC or marvel feel
unbreakable - yeah or you know one like
someone does like when James Gunn did it
super you know yeah like a riff on a
superhero like something something a
little bit strange
yeah like Ryan Gosling and drivers some
kind of hero thing like that this week
has really shown that Gibson it will be
making this comeback and that his
opinion does matter he has a lot to
contribute still to Hollywood I love
your love gives I haven't [ __ ] loved
I don't know recently I watched all the
more lethal live movies again before
watching blood father just to get more
in the mood to watch blood phone bbm
bring back hash tag bring back Mel you
should make t-shirts that's your way to
get some Mouse and that you can
ultimately do a collab with it and if
you want to know why I really believe he
deserves a comeback just check out my
video on it not here to explain myself
again thank you for being here thank
subscribe to the channel especially if
you're new if this is like second or
third time watching a video you still
made a decision well think about like
this is your second or third video
subscribe already yeah if you're already
subscribed
ask yourself do you really want to say
subscribe do you want to tell people you
or subscribe to this channel is that
something you're comfortable with doing
then if you give us Heather or not you
should unsubscribe or not Don is reasons
to Jerry on his Twitter and Instagram
Facebook calm / bloom house and the real
rejects
is a social media manager thing that he
does there and shout out to Danny Glover
hey rude rude